it's a non chat that's a podcast for
otters as we're honors we're welcome to
the odd Cass Jenna Julian podcast where
we talk well things at our favorite rock
and then we put it in our author pocket
the built-in pocket and then you go back
to the seat help so that you don't float
away but if you have another otter you
just hold onto their otter little fool
that's in their hand it won't fall away
it's really cute
otters orders honored cats so you call
each other otters because of that we
told you I know it's gross guys perfect
you're a work now stop trying to have a
relationship with me between have a
relationship between these guys sort of
relationship okay welcome everyone to
the Jenna Angeline podcast thank you so
much for hanging out with us tonight
high five high five high five yeah
actually yeah like actual MPF well today
is uh we decided we would talk about
something that happened today which was
kind of a big event that a lot of people
are talking about which is the Apple
spring forward conference that you know
when I'm unveiling a new line of
computers and giving a lot more
information to the the new Apple watch
that people have been really excited
about including us we're not gonna lie
we ever since mom my like I'm my body's
so ready for that [ __ ] Apple watch
yeah and our friend being keeps making
fun of us cuz he's like no dude it's the
first generation the battery life
doesn't even last the whole day but
she's right there yeah I mean he's not
wrong like there are smart watches
available on the market now that are
probably they could do things better in
some aspects than the Apple watch does
but I don't really care because I'm like
I've been really pumped about it yeah
because I really just want to hook up my
heart rate to your heart rate and John
realized how much more caffeinated a
and you draw a little pictures yeah
little dick pics just draw yeah just
draw you a dick over and over and over
well I think a lot of people are in turn
your train of thought like they don't
really care this is right yeah and I
think another thing is like yeah back in
November or whenever they had their
October when they had the last event
they were like you know early 2015 we're
gonna [ __ ] lie that was guys do you
know what early means [ __ ] off yeah so I
mean obviously there was there had have
been some production issues something
was going on because you'd go on the
website and it would still say early
tornadoes like hello like the last notch
it said that [ __ ] dicks yeah um the
money should I throw it at you like [ __ ]
man take it we'll get to that because a
lot of money is gonna be thrown with
these watches but I wanted summers
[ __ ] a pretty penny man yeah well
Jenna brought up that a friend Bing was
talking about how there are other
watches that do plenty more that are
worth your buck and I want like I want
to be more educated on the SmartWatch
world because I would you know I've I
looked at like CES when it happened this
year and I was just kind of like
browsing around but nothing too serious
and I've seen talent out there there are
some cool stuff I think the problem I
have is like and I'm a little confused
as iPhones are a huge portion of the
cell phone market like massive like
they're uh they're the monopoly right I
mean the majority yeah I would assume I
have I don't think globally maybe not
globally okay well in whatever they have
a big piece of the cell phone yeah
wireless device market and if it
confuses me that's so like I I'm the
little research that I've done on these
these watches I've seen so many cool
ideas and so many cool device is that
none of them work with iPhones is that
right well none of the ones that I've
seen like I've seen so many that are
like like sneakers on has one well
there's a lot of like Android Samsung
you say things like that but then
there's a lot of smartwatches that don't
connect to the phone right that are just
like standalone app but will the the
whole argument about Apple versus you
know an Android or whatever is that
you're just buying into the operating
system so I feel like I'm I'm in the
school of people like we
really [ __ ] care that you guys have
had it for years before we have or that
it works better or that it does cooler
stuff with like we really just we care
about the the Apple operating system and
we're kind of [ __ ] spoiled brats like
once you get a [ __ ] iPhone then you
want an iPad and you want your [ __ ]
Mac computer or in any of that order
you're absolutely absolutely you sort of
fall in love with the operating system
and you don't want to be doing like
[ __ ] different [ __ ] like remember I
was given like a tablet and I'm not
going to say what tablet yeah I remember
it was um not an apple operating system
yeah was it
I don't like I said yeah it's just this
is if er um and I [ __ ] I hated it I
just didn't want to use it I was like oh
I just want to put my coffee on this I
don't like it it feels wrong and I don't
care if it does better stuff like it
really infuriates me every day and mind
you like most people although I don't
know about you but like maybe around my
age you know we went maybe from like
super old max to Windows because Windows
was [ __ ] the gym yeah these are - it
was everywhere and then as we got older
made a choice to go back to Mac yeah but
like my uncle had a super-duper-duper
old Mac computer he like put in the
floppy disk or whatever yeah do [ __ ]
that way he did but then Windows you
know surpassed it so much that you know
if you want to play computer games or
anything you kind of [ __ ] yeah you
better get yourself a PC homey yeah
well yeah I don't know I felt I felt
like it was a big deal like when I was
in college it was still sort of like oh
really like you want you want to use a
Mac computer yeah you sure you want to
do that cuz it's kind of a [ __ ] pet
in the house and I'm like can you just
not can you shut up cuz I really want to
use iMovie dick um that's how I start
making videos but um I think like I'm
just excited for this stupid [ __ ]
watch because although some of them are
way overpriced because you're paying for
rose gold and [ __ ] like that [ __ ]
17 grand or whatever the dick let get
out of my face but you know three
hundred dollars or so for a SmartWatch
that will sync with your phone and do
the coolest [ __ ] ever
I'm sorry I just read today that you can
order an uber with your watch and like
do cool a [ __ ] yeah like [ __ ] $300
for watching no yeah absolutely and
honestly like I think it goes back to
what you're saying about how Apple like
a long time ago when they really started
you know took corner market with the
iPhones everything it's the user
friendly interface that's what gets
people like my grandma can use an iPhone
and understand what's happening yeah
it's like it and it's only gotten easier
and only gotten smoother and so it's
really like it's like you said it's got
to the point where if you have an iPhone
you don't have a different tablet or a
different computer you need everything
to be uniform because it all is so
seamless between devices like it really
is that way and so as much as I get
frustrated by the fact that I feel like
the Apple watch is going to be limited
in some ways and for sure I do have to
remember that if I'm going to be using
my iPhone and then using some separate
watch it is going to be more of a pain I
could not have that I don't know that
uniform but you know who knows I mean I
feel like I'll probably get one of the
base models which is so what you're
saying is like I should I show Jenna
that the price is earlier oh my [ __ ]
god it gets up to around $17,000 because
what's ridiculous is that you know
that's like there are some people that
wanna buy that watch yeah and I think
it's a pieces of [ __ ] it's absolutely
insane and I think Apple knows it's
insane you know what I mean but they're
gonna sell out of those because people I
mean it really is a status thing and
there's enough people who have the money
to buy that but so there's like a sport
version there's like a regular versions
it's a rose gold first generation all
the watch I mean what happens if you
have like a 17 K watch that you buy from
Apple like this isn't just this isn't a
watch that you like go to the jewelers
and buy like this isn't this is a smart
watch so what happens if you get a
cracking screen know what what happens
if I make the operation has been raised
you come up with the second generation
haven't tuned out like that's an inside
I mean but you know what it is it is you
know they're entering the watch market
which the watch markets a lot like that
right so you're paying stupid money for
something that does nothing right but
part of the reason why I like Rolex and
things like that are so expensive is
because they're like they're they're
making all those tiny little gears and
like
way that they create watches is [ __ ]
art why are you laughing
no because because apples the opposite
side is none of that craftsmanship
craftsmanship I mean you can watch that
video over and over again about their
little diamond sapphire or whatever
glass and abla but what's a Klingon
boilage on its small little computer
covered in rose gold which is a
different type of craftsmanship but it's
not the kind that sells for some $2,000
let me ask you a question what would you
pay for a cylindrical generation what
type um with the click wheel it's
[ __ ] probably 15,000 craftsman's yet
no joy I know kind of quickly I mean
five different people worked on that
click wheel for like once what would you
pay for a gold-plated rotary telephone
is the is this spiral accord gold - yes
uh 17,000 what would you pay for a
gold-plated banana phone banana for me
won't you peel it though and you eat it
it's gone what do I get an extra banana
for reference to make sure it's the
right size I don't know like it's just a
little ridiculous know it's it's a very
funny point that you messed it up like
some resale value there's no
craftsmanship like you know a lot of
times with jewelry and things like that
when you buy gold it holds its value
over you know generations that's why a
lot of people keep jewelry in safes they
turn into family heirlooms because it's
it's like you know something that if you
gave it to your granddaughter or
whatever yeah it would still be a
valuable little thing yeah unless it's
like some [ __ ] Paris Hilton
you know necklace or whatever yeah much
case you might want to [ __ ] get a
bodyguard for it yeah but like for the
most part when you buy jewelry and gold
and that sort of thing like a watch like
in our brains we're like alright yeah
okay you know maybe if you bought a
[ __ ] Rolex it's it's you know
whatever you got to find somebody that
wants like a vintage Rolex if you want
to make your money back you're never
gonna ever have any sort of way to make
17 grand back off of your [ __ ] Apple
watch I doubt it yeah I really don't
think it's it's the type of thing
unless it turns into a collector's item
in this case no one gives a [ __ ] like
give me a person that wants to buy even
old anything that's technology watches
everything goes away so fast everything
gets outdated so fast right no you're
right it's no longer jewelry it's more
wearable technology at this point yeah
yeah you know you're right because you
can't I mean as much as you want to and
as much gold as you want to put on an
Apple watch it's not jewelry right it's
technical it's like this is so unrelated
but it is in my mind but you know when
we drive we drive to this hike that's an
Encino and we drove past this giant
[ __ ] house which I had seen on what's
that show million dollar listing a
million dollar listing and Josh the
little whatever the fuse hysterical in
my opinion one of the people on that
show they basically sell these really
expensive houses and this makeup artist
had built himself this like 15 million
dollar mansion in a neighborhood where
houses go for like one to two million
it's what Rome calls king of the
[ __ ] yeah well sir I'm a giant
[ __ ] McMansion in a weird location
yeah like just sort of whatever and it
when we drove past it for the first time
I was like hey that's that house that I
saw it was still on the market for sale
because the guy had literally covered
like you know the toilets and things in
gold and he's like yeah this hat I put
like 20 million dollars into this house
I want 15 for a sell it for me and he's
like nobody wants this that's what I
feel like the Apple watch covered in
gold is it's like you know you're gonna
pay everyone else Nixon has a regular
Apple watch the regular houses and he
bought a gold one to fit money and then
you're gonna be like hello who wants
this like nobody yes sir nobody nobody
wants your stupid gold Apple watch the
people who are buying that gold one are
the people who for them it's worth you
know saying goodbye to that money for
like it's a year it's about a year
because the next version is coming out
and if you have that much stupid money
to spend on one watch the next version
you're going to buy - right and so it's
all about yeah in your mind it's all
about you know saying this is the new
thing of first-of-its-kind looking
I have it right well I mean it's just
it's honestly it's basic just [ __ ]
like utility if you're gonna spend you
know a lot of money on an expensive
piece of jewelry yeah you have to figure
out you know how much am I actually
gonna wear this if I wear it every day
for [ __ ] 20 years yeah yeah maybe
I'll get my money out of it yeah but if
you're if you're gonna wear it for a
year and at $17,000 you're you sir are
making very shitty purchases no yep like
think about a pair of sneakers or
something Pam you pay a hundred dollars
for a pair of sneakers yeah I can get
two three years out of those bad boys
could you rotate them out you know it
means you can you can use your older
ones to go do shitty outdoor shave any
other ones when you don't yeah yeah yeah
you make the most of them get gross
stuff all over your house yeah and all
over the place but like where is where
are you getting $17,000 worth out of
that yeah how much does it cost to make
that if they're charging $17,000 not
$17,000 I probably cost $1,000 if I mean
it might be it might be like it depends
on much one because you the reason it
goes up to seventeen is because of some
of the the wristbands that you that are
going with it like did yours either yeah
or like maybe sterling silver which
isn't 17 K like I just don't understand
where where 17,000 dollars comes from
mm-hmm I don't either
I think it's I mean it's a shock what
they did like these prices are shocking
is it gonna come pre-loaded with Bono's
whole [ __ ] I feel shocked
yeah no Bono's no they're gonna airdrop
on there's an album on it without your
permission no no okay so Bono is gonna
be one of the people that has a $17,000
Apple watch preloaded with his whole
album and he doesn't even want it he
doesn't even want like what what he's
like yes but why would I wear this I
didn't agree to this
oh my god well I mean I don't know I
feel like we're both gonna get the base
model most likely yeah even still I mean
$300 for a watch this is a hefty penny I
mean for a lot of people like well yeah
it's a little bit ridiculous whenever
you said now is money on technology
because you know
it's it can be phased out second item
yeah you're basically buying an iPhone
yeah so but I'm thinking like when I
bought a fuel the engine you bought a
fuel band how much did that cost or 120
bucks something like now so a third of
the price but I would say that I got a
third of the use out of a [ __ ] fuel
band
I'm sorry but I didn't really understand
that fuel points were made up [ __ ]
yeah this time they made they made an
arbitrary measurement yeah I was like
you know I thought fuel it would sort of
like give you an idea of like how many
calories you could eat that day or
something but I'm like what lelee
armature what is it what is it I don't
understand what is a fuel point like
what I like the fuel band but you're
right it's it's complete like who the
[ __ ] signed off and then every time you
go to like the fuel band website it's
like you like search like okay what is
fuel can someone point me to what this
is and no one there's no information
because they don't have to though I go
we made up [ __ ] you you can figure it
out you can buy it cuz I know you're
gonna buy it yeah but you can dance with
it on yeah it's awesome
I mean it's fun cuz you like compete
with your friends you can share it's a
smart marketing thing but it doesn't
mean it's correct agreed but also I
found that like the pedometer was a
little bit off like it wasn't exactly
accurate oh yeah like you could sit I
could sit on my stationary bike and
cycle for hours and it would say that I
didn't do anything today which bothers
me do you know what I mean I'm just not
a bike like this it's not an effective
device I mean it's not you know what
it's its limits are right yeah um but
yeah I feel like I spent $100 on a fuel
band like a lot of people did because it
was exciting that it existed yeah I mean
yeah yeah and it synched with some of
your other things you could use it with
your phone you could [ __ ] you know do
cool [ __ ] and for you know the year or
two I think I use it for losers yeah
you're solid I like I loved it so in my
opinion I got my hundred dollars really
we bought it I made you know one of
those things all tournament so three
hundred dollars is not my favorite price
to pay for a [ __ ] computer watch yeah
but like in in my brain as long as I
[ __ ] like
I don't know I'm just one of those
people if you spend the money on
something I'm like alright I'm gonna get
my [ __ ] money's worth man I'm gonna
order like eight [ __ ] ubers right now
probably watch yeah you know yeah if I'm
gonna draw Julie in a picture of a dick
for my watch all day and I see you like
that my [ __ ] money no wait they're
gonna [ __ ] there's not a camera on it no
is that I don't think so
but that's so weird it is it is how
would you even take a picture
well the Samsung or I don't even know
what you remember Sam chase his brother
came over and he had it that one time he
was like basically it's like [ __ ]
James Bond you're like you looking at
the screen and it's taking a picture
that way and you tap it to take a
picture I mean it's obviously crappy
camera dude I forgot did I forget to
[ __ ] show you this thing it's
basically a wristband I watched a video
and I'm having a hard time understanding
like what level of existence it is right
because it's I camera me the [ __ ]
name I'm kicking myself right now I
watched a whole video about it but it
links with your smartphone it you wear
this little bracelet and then it like
basically projects your phone screen
onto your forearm Wow and you can use it
as if it was my god yeah is that really
is it a concept or is it exists I think
it like might exist but I'm not herbes
incher that's insane do you want to
google it
yeah just google it right now and I'll
talk about what else it does but
basically this [ __ ] this video was
like oh here's some uses for this thing
and there's a guy on his bike and then
all of a sudden he just like taps is
forearm and then like swipes across his
phone screen there's another dude like
in a bathtub yeah what is it sir secret
bracelet
what's it connect your hands alright on
to your wrist yeah holy [ __ ]
pseudonym not kidding oh my God he's
like pinching on a map on his wrist
right so it detects your touch oh this
is creepy right so like this is Circle
it yeah yeah Google that guy's if you
guys want to watch a cool video if
anything is a cool video yeah I'm not
gonna watch it right now but pictures
it's crazy like obviously you know
things exist or people are coming up
with concepts they'll be much more
functional than just a watch that's like
dice some apps on it yes for sure and
like I think it's weird to have a camera
on your rig
and then like what you can only take a
selfie like well you know what here's
the thing like I think her picture it's
very likely that the next version of the
Apple watch will have a camera on it I
feel like for the first version they
wanted to focus on more important things
because when it comes down to it yes
it's very cool you can have a camera on
your watch but it's important to have
the accessibility the touch that the
dial it's important to have the
connectivity like they focused on the
real core things but yeah I mean like I
when I saw Sam's I was like I was very
unimpressed so it's a crappy picture of
someone who doesn't want you to take a
picture because it's on your watch so I
don't really I mean yeah yes I think
they just really need to get him out
there at this point yeah they're really
they doing they're losing their market
share that because people are they're
getting tired of waiting for an Apple
watching they're going to things like
absolutely they're like me they've had
their you know there was more I want I
want wearable tech like I wear my Nike
watch and everybody always at the new
and I'm like no this is like three years
old it may be sometimes get your GPS
when you're running and it's a brick on
top of my arm like I know you know I
couldn't wear as it was too big it's too
big I mean I love it but I'm like ready
to have a SmartWatch like everyone has
smartwatches and I'm like sitting here
everyone has my watches and I'm just
sitting here without a smell meanwhile
my actual watch I like I pulled out one
of the things you know like in a watch
when you pull out the dial to like stuff
or like adjust the time but I like
there's like three things on it and like
one of them to push in and then pull out
and I forgot the order in which you have
to do it so it just stopped a long time
nice so someone will be like what time
is it and I'm like ah I forgot how this
works so that's right twice a day oops
laughs that sucks
whoops whoops yeah I'm [ __ ] I'm ready
for the Apple watch and I want the sport
one I don't understand
oh this 4.2 what the heck look I mean at
this way a lot of people like to wear
their watch or something to the gym
because like you bring your phone to the
gym like you bring your technology with
yeah yeah yeah yeah Jen oh absolutely
like if you do any sort of physical
activity it's hard for me to understand
you wouldn't buy a sport watch because
you can get like you can switch out some
of the [ __ ] bands right yeah they're
all all the bands are it's [ __ ]
cheaper and the plastic bands are the
like colorful ones or what a dope they
seem cooler they see my cooler and it's
like customizable like third parties are
gonna make a killing on the bands you
know third party they're gonna cream
eating that that's the huge market I
mean when I had the little the iPod mini
yeah yeah with you I bought the the
little watch band that you could nano
yeah no sorry that's a screen
slide the that was a big thing yes for
the watch yeah I had one of the watches
for a long time it was just the iPod
yeah that's like a that was like a made
out of Apple watch yeah exactly
and the worst part about it was like if
you wanted to listen to it you had to be
plugged into your wrist that was a
little annoying what are you doing being
an idiot oh yeah yeah no I would be like
I'll go on a walk and I'm like I gotta
have ones I'll just listen to my watch
yeah so I'll plug it in I start walking
the dogs and we just rip it how'd it
make you so just it's just dysfunction
to the core
it was so bad oh we gotta be so bad Plus
like um the screen wouldn't really stay
on ever yeah like all the time is it
what kind of watch is that oh it's just
an iPod cool what time is so like hold
on let me get to the living
time screen oh my headphones just fell
out once that's funny
um yeah I mean well while we're on the
theme of Apple and what happened today
have you haven't heard about the new
MacBooks no all right we're at talking
about it okay no I want to talk to us
because it's interesting yeah they
released a line of new MacBooks and then
this is the first time I think in like a
few years that they have named something
a MacBook it's either been MacBook Pro
and MacBook Air in the last three years
or so I don't know exactly but it's a
MacBook it's very very thin people are
even calling it the MacBook Air because
it looks so thin but it's they have it
in gold space gray and silver like the
iPhones now and touch screen it's not I
mean like can you hold your thumb on to
it well unlocks no okay no there's a
Retina display and one of the biggest I
want to get to something
I think is a little interesting to talk
about after this but they have a new
touch sensor on the trackpad it's it's
like a force technology so like how well
you can press different levels of hard
like saying break it faster no no
opposite you press you can rage what you
push more you push more with more force
to do certain tasks and you can you
basically like have 10 times of control
of the normal trackpad so it's very cool
like I watched the kinara it's very cool
the thing that I think is a little odd
is they literally have one port on the
entire computer what let me explain it's
called USB see USB - see right I'm
already and if it's a charger the new
charger of course not the max right it's
a new one if it's a USB if it's HDMI so
it fits all the ones you would need but
there's there's only one and I think
hold on I think at first I was like that
too I said what the [ __ ] no but and
here's the thing it's got 10 no like 50
something big battery life like a long
long battery life because they literally
cleaned out the whole interior the
computer and put extra batteries in
never long enough but you're right it's
never long enough but a lot of people
like wait what if I want to like have my
iPod iPod or iPhone plugged in and and
my charger plugged in or what if I want
to be you know anything besides charging
my thing what if and it doesn't make the
most sense but at the same time this
thing is like a $1300 machine and
college students are buying this like
people who don't do [ __ ] where you have
a million devices plugged in or buying
this so in other words you or me we
would never buy this it makes zero sense
we edit we have drives and you cannot
you can't this is for the casual
Microsoft Word I have Facebook I'm on
you know somebody makes a charger that
then has extra they do Apple is going to
sell it for like 50 bucks okay so it's
just an attachment but I guess what they
were trying to do is like really throw
it in our face that like this $1300
Retina display with this insane
technology and battery and new
everything yeah you know you're not
going to get a million ports you're
getting one and it's going to work with
everything but you
to figure out the best way to make it
work so that's I mean this is me playing
devil's advocate like Apple's advocate
this is me thinking how they're thinking
up in my own mind okay can I play the
other edge yeah do it let's do it [ __ ]
off why are you gonna [ __ ] do that
[ __ ] off you're telling me that I at
least I have the choice of plugging in
my computer or anything else that's my
choice if I want to plug in one thing
I'll get an iPad and I'll plug it into
the wall I have a lot I have a question
though what my I don't understand why
you can why you can justify selling a
laptop without giving us the ability to
plug in the [ __ ] that you already sold
us I'm not disagreeing I'm playing
devil's advocate but no no you aren't
I'm not angry at you yeah um if you
think about it anyone who's doing
something serious on a computer eh isn't
doing it on a laptop so maybe they're
trying to separate their markets they're
trying to upsell these people by they're
setting themselves up to unveil the most
insane MacBook Pro there ever is like in
a couple in their next at their next
event we're gonna unveil a MacBook Pro
with the new touch thing except it's
going to be [ __ ] a little thicker
it's going to last like two [ __ ] days
it's going to have three ports on each
side like it's going to be like the you
know not the real Mac Pro it's going to
be the lap the portable version of the
best thing you can get from Mac right
but then so this is like such a vicious
love-hate relationship cycle right I
agree is that you know they they
convince you that something is so sleek
and simple and sexy so you buy it and
then they put out something that's more
functional it makes that irrelevant and
makes that obsolete yeah that's what
they do they're doing it themselves but
it's not only it's like it's not a bad
plan well I just want to know because
Bret was really excited about this
laptop because he doesn't currently have
a lab job and I think someone like Bret
is a perfect example of who could really
use that computer absolutely find it
nice and function that's the perfect
computer for Bret right because you
don't need a plug-in
8-billion comes into it yeah and even if
you do that battery life will take you
for as long as you're going to need to
right yeah
you're not using it for anything other
than you know working like small amounts
of work browsing processing whatever um
but for yet that like literally gives my
body anxiety thinking about one port
like I feel like I'm gonna explode right
now yeah I mean I had one two three four
five six
mmm no I mean I've eight freaking out of
the end nine ports on my macbook pro
right now this is the MacBook Pro Retina
and I use every single one of those
ports every single day I literally use
all the ports version of that yeah
not one port no yeah no I agree and I
think I think you said it perfectly you
said they're trying to separate their
mark mark yeah it's it's exactly that's
what I would think they're doing well
yeah because there's there's lots of
people that love to work on a laptop for
web browsing they need word processing
piping write essays it what yeah
college student yeah college this is
huge but [ __ ] so it's $1,300 I think
it's so Jeana that's yeah $30.00 it's 12
inches man I feel like mmm okay I've
been in college no no no I'm about to
flip out like $1,300 for one point I'd
be so Inger if I was a college student
like even though Apple sometimes gives
you that 10% discount for your student
or whatever I'd be like nah dude you're
gonna be one port you're gonna give me
like a nice thing that I can take to
school why isn't it cost [ __ ] $800
why because they have a brand-new track
pad that you can do each I dad cuz I'm
gonna get a [ __ ] Mouse for the thing
anyways it's gotten a Retina display
where do you tell the [ __ ] difference
when I'm like looking at shitty ass
gossip websites one thing I did see is
that on the camera they explode the
camera on the new MacBooks guess what
quality that camera what quality is 480p
that's like 2005 they put a 480p camera
on the Mac books they announced today
the one that faces you like those yeah
480 that's what you see a YouTube video
is when it first uploads and it hasn't
rendered yet and people are like you
shoot his own potato that is
what it is it's a potato camera 480p on
a Retina display computer $1,300 I think
that is the biggest sadist ripoff I've
ever heard of and that makes me upset
the camera thing is kind of stupid I am
sort of grasping the one port although
it doesn't seem very very it doesn't
seem like the best route they could have
taken I think I don't know it makes me
angry that's like that's it makes me
feel like Apple trying to sell me an
outlet like one outlet and then they
they also sell you all these other
really cool things but they're like
guess what if you want to plug them in
to use them you're only gonna get one
plug yeah you know honestly I think I
think the head of I you know I think the
guys who are the team who had been work
I don't know how the [ __ ] anything works
so if I say something ignorant just like
yell at me in the comments but the you
know whoever was in charge did bills in
charge of this yeah well your brother
would probably laugh at how I'm saying
this because he knows how you know how
this kind of stuff works but basically I
would feel like the team who is in
charge of the MacBook Airs you know got
a lot of them got assigned to this new
MacBook project and they were thinking
well you know what's the best way that
we can make this new and sleek and sexy
with a couple new features while also
like really really oversimplified like
really to the point where every parent
is going to say yeah I'm gonna get you
this one when you go to college I'm not
getting you a MacBook Pro you know for
fit you know twenty twenty two hundred
dollars when I could spend back the
money yeah you get this one yeah it's
smaller it'll fit in your backpack
better when you're riding your bike to
class like you know what I mean
everything about it like just screams
college student and you know what as you
laptop they really should just call it
the MacBook [ __ ] college student then
don't [ __ ] call it a MacBook Logan I
hear you or the MacBook s like how they
came out with iPhone s like the cheaper
version of it yeah yeah yeah I'm like
thinking about one point high V I'm like
I feel like I'm itchy your hands getting
itchy I can't like it's literally giving
me anxiety
I mmm oh my god I can't you know IKEA
that's a cute tag it makes me so angry I
don't think I've been this angry in like
this is why this is where I didn't tell
you about it into the
because I wanted this reaction to cool
surprise really yeah because you know
how hi viewers why this is I'm happy
you're giving a raw reaction this is
what I like oh my god I know what I'm
getting you for your birthday what no
one for it only if I can throw it only
thinking like Jam a carrot and it's one
pork tell it to [ __ ] off you know what's
[ __ ] up is like husband as much like a
person who's getting is high V and
frustrated as you are right now at this
idea can watch the keynote and still be
like looks nice I'm sure it does look
beautiful and they're great sales feels
a lot of fun they really make you want
that [ __ ] okay I mean they're good that
is just not functional unless you are
taking it into a college class and
typing your notes on it you know what
here's the thing I'm a you know I'm
seriously [ __ ] let me interrupt you
it's basically an iPad with one port
it's not a [ __ ] computer no it's a
computer that's a computer my iPad has a
better camera than that thing yes okay
thirty good think about No think about
the young girls and boys in college that
are making a [ __ ] side living off of
like running a dirty web cam it means to
stay dirty how are they they're trying
to push webcams to the Past that's why
the game is she wants to run they're
like they're coeds you know many porn
site from their dorm room you stream it
from your phone cuz it's got a ten times
better camera everyone's got an iPhone
that's how apples like okay if you guys
are rocking webcams to make your
paycheck get out
use a Dell you know you mean use Lenovo
God but I mean here's the thing I am on
the fence I'm on the fence about the
port and I think part of it could be
smart and part of it can be really dumb
but this is one of those things where I
really feel like in like five years
we're going to have a whole section of
the laptop market that is going to have
one port and it's going to be the casual
users market and this is the first time
or at least the first time I've seen it
may not be the first release of it there
might be another laptop but I'm saying
this is the first time it's been really
in the public eye we're a big company
came out with a product that seemed like
this is not cutting it but I think in
five years people are going to say you
know
remember that first everyone thought it
was crazy with one part but now an
entire giant section of the laptop
population are only using one part
because who the [ __ ] needed all those
ports we didn't realize until we only
had one right well yeah no I think it's
a valid point but I think in order for
the general consensus to be was that you
know that what a forward-thinking thing
that is a great one port is that you
need to make it work with all the things
we need to plug into our computer
because if you're using your computer to
compute things sometimes you need a
[ __ ] plug [ __ ] into it that's why an
iPad doesn't have a port and your phone
doesn't have a port and that's ok
because you don't really need a plug
[ __ ] into your phone or your iPad
because you're not computing with it
yeah I mean yeah so it like what you
said that it works with your power cord
and it works with the USB cord that's
fine I only need one port if it's gonna
work with a bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
but if you're just gonna give me one
[ __ ] port and it's not gonna be able
to use I can't plug in my [ __ ] then [ __ ]
off you don't I mean yeah we'll see I
mean honestly I feel you know I feel you
there's there's like there's been so
many times everyone's been there where
you look you know you normally leave
your from your your computer on the
charger when you're good but sometimes
you forget and then you come home and
you really really need to do something
urgently and it's dead what do you do
you can't plug anything in you got to
charge it and then when it gets to 3%
then you try to plug in your phone no
it's not you got you know you mean like
that presents a serious issue hmm so you
know are ya there being a way around
that there's miss god forbid you ever
want to use your your pretty little
computer after college and you want to
maybe you know plug some [ __ ] into your
[ __ ] laptop because now your job is
different than what it was when you were
19 you got to sell that thing and get a
real computer it's not a full computer I
know I know that's what I'm thinking
because you know I had my first like my
my laptop I got it my either junior or
senior year of college because I had a
big desktop PC I didn't have a laptop
yeah and you know I used that thing for
a couple of years at that point that was
a long life cuz I had a tower yeah you
know I mean yeah legit PC and um I think
it was my senior year I got the little
Macca and I ran that thing into the
ground and then I got the the other
MacBook or whatever they were ones the
older version of what youth exactly Pro
not ready yeah but I coughed up that
[ __ ] money myself and was like
alright I want this like I can do
everything I want from this yeah and I
didn't get a desktop because it wasn't
at that point where I could really just
[ __ ] you know sit there and work yeah
yeah for sure
and I made all my videos on that but
like that [ __ ] that white MacBook
that I got my senior year of college in
the course of a year I was using that
thing for such different things yeah
like if I had gotten a computer with one
port and you know was like oh this is
great cuz I'm a senior in college and ha
ha ha
he put it in my backpack so great and
then you know a couple years later I was
doing something completely [ __ ]
different yeah I'd be so [ __ ]
yeah and I'd be furious because it was
not a cheap and right it's not cheap
when you were that young and you need a
[ __ ] you know make a living oh that
thing it's it's your your entire life
and you don't realize it maybe when you
buy it when you're in college yeah until
you're out of college and you can barely
afford to feed yourself but that is your
workhorse I agree you know yep it may
serve a day may serve a different and
more important purpose than when you
initially it bought it
right especially given you know how many
people you know upload [ __ ] from their
phones and their [ __ ] whatever like
you you want to plug in [ __ ] to your
computer yeah I mean yeah it seems a
little bit frustrating because I didn't
really understand who else that computer
is for at the current moment well like
you said I mean like a person my breath
who a person who's going to be on the
Internet
a person is going to be you know maybe
typing more documents or sending emails
or listening to music or watching
Netflix like the casual user can 99% of
the time I feel like if I would this
thing but the moment you want to do more
with this expensive computer you bought
you can't what so that's what I think is
frustrating yeah that's what hurts my
heart it's one-dimensional right yeah no
I hear you because I was that person
and then my life changed drastically and
you need if I needed like that made it I
need my first computer I would like
sometimes I would sit there and cry and
eventually it turned into a desktop
because it no longer worked unless it
was plugged in and that's how kits that
my power cords I like I thought I needed
that thing yeah you know Oh [ __ ] lol
life man lol that's just what hurts my
heart is that the people that might buy
that computer when you're really
stretching yourself to make that
purchase yeah and then all of a sudden
you're like wait a second my life is now
drastically different I need to sell
this but I can never get you know as
much money back like because you're
going to be needing to buy a more
expensive computer anyways and then you
can sell it for like half of what you
bought it for if because nobody wants
your creepy old laptop they wanna go
create I want a good deal they want you
to drive it to their house things loves
Craigslist you know what I mean yeah
yeah I do and then you're gonna [ __ ]
yep
well it's I mean it's like like you know
you like it or you hate it or you get
hyvee about it you're talking about it
this is a really big day you know I mean
it's a different type of event than app
normally has which is interesting
yeah I may not be interested to see what
people think aren't you - and I'm
interested to see in the coming months
what happens like reactions of actually
touching the products I'm sure I'm sure
one poor fantastic for some people but
I've been given the amount of things get
plugged into my computer my like every
[ __ ] port is it it makes me nauseous
I feel like I'm falling off of you and
me you and me you we Scott for that kind
of thing I mean it's like I don't stuff
I'm like genuinely fresh out on the
inside I know it makes me hot like I'm
Scott I'm sorry did you say scoff scoff
scoff uh I didn't even get that
reference now right I really want to
know leave in the comments whether
you're watching or listening if how you
guys feel about the Apple watch and what
you guys think yes please computer
having one port that can yeah a power
cord
tell us why yeah and tell us why one of
us you disagree with you know or agree
with like I want to hear why would I
it's stupid or why what I said is
agreeing with you yeah but um yeah like
I like to imagine that you have the
choice of either project plugging in
your drive or plugging in your computer
that's a headache I don't want to think
about that that makes me angry hands are
actually sweating though my hands are
getting itchy Dino ROM goes through
there's good podcast [ __ ] can't even
I really do want an apple watch a thing
before you know yeah well if we you know
if we do get them with some point we got
to just like play with them on the
podcast enemies and while you're talking
I'm just gonna send you a dick pic
I'll give you an in-depth review of what
it feels like to receive a dick pic I'm
just gonna write I'm just you're gonna
say something I disagree with I'm gonna
write scoff and send it to you Oh Scott
I'm not gonna know what it says yeah
it's gonna feel like a legend
oh my and I having a heart attack no
that's my watch anyway um yeah good talk
Apple progress yeah thank you guys for
listening and watching a podcast yeah we
appreciate love you guys we'll see you
in the comments
cya Internet one court one more and
we'll see you guys next week on Monday
for another podcast SoundCloud iTunes
everything in a set will love you pour
one quart
one one poor one port Oh even humans
have like three ports oh my god it is
over done